[Musik]
ich würde sagen irgendwie mit wenn man
dir die
verschiedene
[Musik]
jetzt
ganz genau aber sie sind
und jetzt habe ich schon
[Musik]
wie viel das ist genauso weil sie nicht
aber ich glaube beim Aussage
[Musik]
wer jung in die Schulden Gerät findet
oft lange nicht mehr heraus
[Musik]
das Leben ist teuer in der Schweiz wer
nicht viel verdient muss sein Geld gut
einteilen vielen jungen fällt das schwer
[Musik]
zur Kündigung kam kurz darauf die
Lohnpfändung es ist nicht ihre erste
Kiri lebt schon seit sie volljährig ist
mit Schulden
vom betriebsamt
wie wichtig dass das eigentlich ist dass
man weiß wo das man steht und hat
einfach nur schliefen
heute lebt sie auf dem Existenzminimum
sie hat sich ihrer Mutter anvertraut ein
Wege Zimmer gesucht und sich ein Ziel
gesetzt
und ja
seit kurzem hat sie Ordnung in ihrem
Postfach die Situation am Briefkasten
ist für viele überschuldete ein Problem
also eigentlich
da und tatsächlich gefühlt
das Geld aus zu mir am Arm sie liegt das
eigentlich
wieder andere deswegen
Kiri steht ganz am Anfang ihrer
Schuldensanierung und versucht es noch
ohne professionelle Hilfe
Erika Müller ist schon einiges weiter
auch sie ist mit der Volljährigkeit in
die Schulden gerutscht als vor
eineinhalb Jahren gar nichts mehr ging
hat sie bei der Schuldenberatung Hilfe
gesucht und hat seither keine
Lohnpfändungen mehr
ja ja schaut auch ein Auto für
duschsacht aber
nicht nur das
die 35-Jährige lastwagenfahrerin ist bei
einer Stadt im Mittelland angestellt und
hätte kein Problem gehabt sich zu zeigen
aber ihr Arbeitgeber wollte das nicht
die Idee ist ja vor der ganzen
nach drei Jahren
Erika Müller verdient 5000 Franken und
zahlt nach einem Sanierungsplan
monatlich 1750 ab sie ist eher die
Ausnahme
nur 10% der Klienten hier können alle
Schulden zurückzahlen
wenn wir jetzt noch
mit dem abzahlen
4 Jahre dass man mit den Steuern nicht
nachkommt passiert oft und hat man eine
Lohnpfändung werden die Steuer nicht
einmal ins Existenzminimum eingerichtet
das macht es noch schlimmer
zum Beispiel gekommen
verpflichtige genügend
in dieser Situation hat Erika Müller
einen Kleinkredit von 10.000 Franken
aufgenommen
weil der Kredit gegen das
Konsumkreditgesetz versteht konnte die
Schuldenberatung diese Forderung massiv
reduzieren
aus Konsumkrediten sind total in der
Schweiz etwa 7,7 Milliarden Franken
ausstehen
5% der Haushalte sind damit in Verzug
Desinteresse oder Unwissen ist in
jugendlichem Alter häufig die Folgen
aber sind verteilt
Eve de Mistral beschäftigt sich seit
Jahren mit überschuldeten Menschen und
weiß mit der Volljährigkeit explodieren
die Betreibungen in der Schweiz um den
Faktor 70
Franken 100 Franken und aber auch
ziemlich 100 Frank 350 krank
[Musik]
Themen wie diese sind im Lehrplan nicht
vorgesehen darum bietet die
Schuldenprävention Zürich für
Oberstufenklassen Infoveranstaltungen an
etwa in jedem siebten Haushalt in der
Schweiz gibt es Zahlungsrückstände
von mir ist wichtig dass man seine
Finanzen kennt und Überblick sein Geld
nehmt das mal hervor das Budget das hier
gemacht habt ich möchte dass ihr eure
Budgets miteinander vergleichen
genau
ist hilft es wenn man schon früh seinen
finanziellen Rahmen kennt
zum zur Sache konsumieren ich kann
morgen um zwei wenn ich verwacher kann
ich das Internet und ich innerhalb von
zwei Minuten
praktisch
ohne Probleme dieser
Oberstufenschülerinnen und Schüler
beginnen bald mit einer Lehre und haben
mit ihren Eltern unterschiedliche Budget
Abmachungen getroffen
[Musik]
Eltern sind wichtige Vorbilder auch in
finanziellen Fragen
aber trotzdem sparen
und ich würde dann ich denke noch mal ob
ich so Geld habe dann einfach das wird
halt sowieso sucht und muss es halt
lernen wie mit Geld um Gott
normalerweise
wieder Halt weggegangen also jetzt
gerade noch nicht so viel Geld das
Problem ist einfach dass man sich nicht
bewusst ist was man kann ausstellen wenn
das wenn ich diese Situation nicht
vor 20 gültig aber der kümmere deine
Moment
heißt aber dass der Gläubiger der muss
Scout schuldet die nächste 20 Jahre
wieder drauf und die Betriebe wieder neu
in Gang setzen es gibt ganz viele
Menschen wo wahrscheinlich
das ist natürlich sehr sehr dramatisch
Donald Niebaum ist einer von ihnen er
ist auch sehr jung in die Schulden
geraten Jahre später ist sein
Schuldenberg auf 87.000 Franken
angewachsen
heute morgen
mittlerweile hat er eine Familie seine
Partnerin ist ebenfalls verschuldet
weder sie noch der gemeinsame Sohn
möchten sich in diesem Film äußern
[Musik]
trotz Schulden kauft Donald das Gemüse
auf dem Markt
das ist mir einfach mega viel wert und
da könnte ich noch so viel bandigen und
Betriebe
seit Jahren leben er und seine Partnerin
mit einem Existenzminimum von 3.800
Franken obwohl er regelmäßig arbeitet
in die Schulden geraten ist der
ausgebildete Maurer weil er beim Auszug
aus seiner ersten Wohnung ein
auszugsprotokoll unterschrieben hat auf
dem große Schäden aufgelistet waren die
er gar nicht verursacht hatte
am Anfang ist
und sich nicht darum kümmern und
irgendwann ist ein ziemlich schnell noch
zwei drei Jahre mit den betriebigen und
lohnpfändigen ist übrig zum
zum resignieren
über die Jahre haben sich so auch
Krankenkassen und Steuerschulden
angehäuft Betreibungen reiten sich
aneinander aus den Lohnpfändungen kam er
gar nicht mehr heraus
organisiert sich aber im Alltag ist es
andauernde Belastung eigentlich
gut überlegen
hat alles andere Mal
muss dann ihnen ausschauen
nach 15 Jahren haben er und seine
Partnerin sich endlich aufgerafft etwas
dagegen zu tun
[Musik]
der wandelt
und der wirkliche Schritt zu der
Schuldenberatung eigentlich sieht dass
sie das Schreiben
eine weitere Jugendsünde Donald war ein
leidenschaftlicher Sprayer und wurde
wegen Sachbeschädigung mehrfach gebüst
weil er eine 15.000 frankige Buße nicht
bezahlen kann muss er sie nun absetzen
jetzt hofft er dass die Schuldenberatung
helfen kann
Franziska Neuhaus ist heute 39 sie hat
den Weg aus den Schulden nach 20 langen
Jahren endlich fast geschafft doch sie
hat einiges in ihrem Leben ändern müssen
das Hobby der gelernten reisefachfrau
ist nähen
[Musik]
Trainer hätte die wahrscheinlicher
günstigeren verkaufen müssen oder hätten
gar nicht gebraucht und wirklich nur ein
Stoff wenn ich ein Buch unter dir
sie sucht Stoff um eine TUI für ihren
E-Reader zu nähen
heute hat sie unterschiedliche Konten
mit unterschiedlichem Zugriff
von der Prepaid-Kreditkarte mit der
Prepaid Kreditkarte nicht mit
sackgeldkonto der Gott jeden Monat den
Tag 800 frankendorf und das ist mit die
Freizeit
die Sachen und nicht mehr gehen
bitte bitte
Sparkonto zum Beispiel Online-Banking
für mich als eigene
Ratenzahlungen kommen für sie heute
nicht mehr in Frage
das ist für mich
auch Franziskas Geschichte ist typisch
und hat früh begonnen SRF hat schon 2004
über sie berichtet
damals war sie 21 und mit 8000 Franken
verschuldet auch sie ist mit dem Auszug
von zu Hause in die Schulden geraten
für Kollegen
irgendwelche Tür gekauft eine halbe Jahr
später
gegangen ist
vieles kaufte sie online und wenn Sie
Ihre Handyrechnung nicht mehr bezahlen
konnte wechselte sie einfach den
Anbieter an die Steuerrechnung dachte
sie gar nicht und anvertrauen wollte sie
sich auch niemandem
Situation
eigentlich extrem geschämt kann ich habe
mich nicht getraut mit Kollegen
mit dem Problem
letzte Betrieb
erst als sie ihre Miete nicht mehr
bezahlen konnte und kurz vor einer
Lohnpfändung stand ging sie zur
Schuldenberatung und ließ sich zeigen
wie man ein Budget macht
ich bin in anex Sessel hat mir die
Rechnungen und alles sortiert und haben
den auch gemerkt dass es zum Teil recht
hoch überträgt sind und ich nicht
zurückzahlen und haben den mit der
Gläubiger Kontakt aufgenommen zum mit
ihnen abzahlungsvertrag abzumachen damit
ich meine Schultern im monatlichen
ungefähr ein Jahr meine Schulden in
einem monatlichen
Franziska schien ihre Situation in den
Griff zu bekommen und hielt sich an ihr
Budget
also ich bin ich fertig mit dem abzahlen
von meiner Schulter ich bin mega froh
ist endlich fertig das wieder mal
richtig ein Leben dass ihr wieder kein
Geld auf und ja irgendwo
ja aus dem üblichen
Lieder
dass ich ja eigentlich mit viel weniger
glücklich zu heutigen Zeitpunkt
das war 2004
18 Jahre später weiß sie dass sie viel
zu optimistisch war
sie verdient 5.500 Franken im Monat
davon gingen über Jahre 7 bis 800
Franken für die Schuldentilgung weg also
ganz schuldefrei bin ich
in
vor Jahren
[Applaus]
einfach so und haben das sehr großzügig
ausgenutzt die Zeit um sich Franken und
bin da immer noch aktiv am abzahlen
fertig
nie hätte sie gedacht dass es so viel
schwieriger ist aus den Schulden
herauszukommen als rein zu geraten
[Musik]
und so weiter das sind alles in dem
Moment für mich sehr hoch gebastelt
schon andere geratenzahlungen abgemacht
haben und da seid das wie immer wieder
Verzögerungen
heute lebt Franziska mit ihrem Freund
zusammen für sie war von Anfang an klar
die Finanzen müssen sauber geregelt sein
Lebensmittel Putzmittel
kontrollieren
das ist das immer völlig frei und und
ja das läuft einfach für größere Jahre
schaffen
ja für mich okay
komisch gesehen also ich rede mit dem
Kraftwerk aber
schnell akzeptiert und ihre probiert
in diesem Raum
gemacht hat wenigstens früher gemacht
hätte oder so es muss zurück
Ferien zum Beispiel machen die beiden
nur tageweise und er in der Schweiz
[Applaus]
Donald macht schon lange keine Ferien
mehr die letzten 15 Jahre lebte er
praktisch immer mit Lohnpfändungen und
auf dem Existenzminimum jetzt mit Hilfe
der Schuldenberatung ist er erstmals
nach langer Zeit wieder draußen
bitte Schuldenberatung gemacht
dann wurde mein Monat Hornis erstmals
[Gelächter]
auf der Schuldenberatung hat man Donald
aufgetragen sich einen Überblick über
seine Ausgaben zu verschaffen er hat
ziemlich Respekt davor ich weiß wie
Heiko dass sie sich was passiert
und
ich habe mich laber lang habe ich das
nie
die Verantwortung übernommen
darum fühle ich mich schon so sehr sehr
schwach und dem nicht unbedingt wachsen
Ei ich hoffe es mehr
glad natürlich
aber die Schuldenspirale hört nicht zu
schnell auf sich zu drehen
schon wieder hat er vom Betreibungsamt
eine Vorladung erhalten
mittlerweile ist der dort ein alter
Bekannter
Befehl
klar das wirkt nicht
2000 Franken hoch sind aber eben das
abgestumpften es ist also ja
Weg sie und so ja
genau
also per Hit wäre das insgesamt 493
Franken 82
eine neue Lohnpfändung sollte er damit
abwenden können aber seine schuldenliste
ist lang der eintrandige hat mir
vollkommen momentan
einfach probieren
Zukunft können bescheren standen
[Musik]
auf seine neue Bankkarte hat der extra
das nötige Geld geladen
[Musik]
doch er hat zu knapp kalkuliert
aber das Betreibungsamt zeigt sich
kulant und rundet ausnahmsweise um ein
paar Gebühren Franken ab
wichtig für sie super danke
[Musik]
aber jetzt zu mal so wie froh sage ich
die Pfanne
und ist nicht zum vollen
ist auch Chef des betreibungsamtes
Zürich 3 und über Donald Situation
informiert
sinnvoll dass man würden
Shop im Start von meiner
Entschuldigung
es ist erfolgreich
geht es vielen Menschen
allein im Jahr 2020 wurden in der
Schweiz
2,67 Millionen Betreibungen eingeleitet
der Mistral ist schon lange im Geschäft
und hat den Überblick über die Zahlen
die Betriebsart sind ganz klar
Krankenkassenprämie das wird der
Meisterbetriebe
was volumenmäßig vom betragsvolumen am
meisten muss macht den Studierenden
rund 7,5% der Schweizer Bevölkerung
leben in einem Haushalt mit mindestens
einer überfälligen Steuerrechnung
5,5% sind mit Krankenkassenprämien im
Verzug
das ist eine Besonderheit in der Schweiz
reaktiv Lohnabzug führt für krankasse
übrigens auch
und man muss in der Schweiz nicht
langsam oder
Krankenkassenbeiträge direkt vom Lohn
abziehen politisch schwierig in der
Schweiz wo man Eigenverantwortung
hochhält
doch das hätte Erika sehr geholfen auch
bei ihr hat sich die Schuldenspirale
wegen Steuer und Krankenkassen Schulden
immer schneller gedreht
diese Situation hat ihr in den letzten
zehn Jahren psychisch massiv zugesetzt
mit 18
hat Krankenkassen nicht auszahlt ist
im Endeffekt 25
ein Klinikaufenthalt war unausweichlich
erst auf Drängen ihrer Therapeutin hat
sie bei der Schuldenberatung angerufen
die Zugehörigkeit zu einem
fastnachtsverein hat ihr sehr geholfen
jedes Jahr näht sie ihr Kostüm möglichst
günstig um
von Kollegium
dass ich von der autokostüme mit
aber auch im Verein hat sie belastende
Erfahrungen gemacht Schulden haben ist
ein Tabu redet man darüber kommt es
meist nicht gut an wenn wir das
festlegen
dass sie extrem krass
[Musik]
Erika hat immer gearbeitet
soziale Kontakte und Anerkennung aus dem
Umfeld beides ist wichtig um aus der
Negativspirale herauszukommen auch
donald hat er immer einen Job
aber erst vor drei Jahren hat er den
gefunden der wirklich zu ihm passt
das hat geholfen
früherer
sprayen Alkohol da muss ich sagen
eigentlich aufgehört haben
das ist definitiven
seine Firma arbeitet ausschließlich mit
Naturfarben
so viel dünn erschaffen in
verschiedensten Materialien
eigentlich genau für die Renovation
eines Hauses muss er den richtigen
Farbton für die Fensterläden finden
aber seine Vergangenheit holt ihn immer
wieder ein die 15.000 franken-busse aus
seinen sprayer-aktivitäten hat das
Gericht nun in einen Vollzug von drei
Monaten umgewandelt den Donalds mit
Fußfesseln absetzen muss
seine finanzielle Situation und die
Geschichte mit den Fußfesseln hat er im
Geschäft aber immer sofort kommuniziert
mal dann muss das gestanden ist quasi
ablecken will so verkrampftig in dir
selber und der wird immer schwieriger
mit dem Drucken
sehr froh du würdest mir da die ewz
aufwerten auch
Donalds Chef GC entspannt mit seiner
Schuldensituation um für mich ist das
eigentlich überhaupt kein Problem also
[Musik]
Mitarbeiter also ein Kollege also über
sehr sehr Wert und mich als Arbeitgeber
interessiert was er kann und was er will
und wo er higa will und wenn er sich
entwickelt
auch das Donald bald mit Fußfesseln zur
Arbeit kommen wird stört die nicht das
ist für mich
er wird seine Leistung da machen und
wird Donald Trump
also ja
interessiert mich eigentlich nicht groß
viel mehr interessiert er sich für
Donalds Kunst
dieser hat eine alte Technik auf
Kalkplatten mit seinem Sprayer Know-how
kombiniert
sein Chef finde es spannend wenn man
diese Platten verkaufen könnte und
vielleicht wäre es gar eine neue
Einnahmequelle die Donald helfen könnte
aus den Schulden herauszukommen
[Musik]
im Internet irgendwie und so und das hat
für mich nicht ich mache da für mich die
Platte und verkauft und
irgendwann
geschafft könnte das Auftrag machen
dann wäre das auch wieder ganz
[Musik]
profitieren auch andere Leute
wie schwierig es ist wenn keine
Stabilität im Job da ist zeigt die
Situation von Kiri die 24-Jährige Job
Teilzeit und ist in eine WG gezogen weil
sie ihre Wohnung nicht mehr bezahlen
konnte
sie steht vor einem ziemlichen
Scherbenhaufen und muss schauen dass
möglichst bald mehr Geld reinkommt
[Musik]
eigentlich sehr schwer darauf hoffe aber
ich habe getragen
oh ja ich hoffe einfach darauf dass der
chefle ich mir die Chance geht und ähm
mit mir also ja bei mir Frauen die
Chance geben
Kiri ist zum wiederholten Mal in einer
Lohnpfändung und lebt darum auf dem
Existenzminimum
ist rund 2700 Franken
[Musik]
alles was Kiri darüber hinaus verdient
im Moment sind das vier bis 500 Franken
im Monat behält das Betreibungsamt zur
Schuldensanierung
relativ lange
das verstanden habe
das heißt oder im Betrieb
das heißt
ich hoffe sie hat irgendwann
kommen und so schnell
ob sie das geschafft hat und wie es ihr
in der Zwischenzeit geht wissen wir
nicht Kiri war nach diesem Dreh nicht
mehr erreichbar und hat auf diverse
Mails und SMS auch nicht reagiert
donald hat regelmäßig Termine auf der
Schuldenberatung
er verdient etwa 4.800 Franken im Monat
jetzt geht es erstmal ums grundlegende
ist es wichtig dass jetzt lernen das
Geld wir gar nicht mit dem Geld um und
gerade
Lebensmittel ist es wichtig dass Sie das
richtige Teilen Ihrem Fall sind das
ungefähr 240 Franken
die 240 Franken
und ihnen
und ihre Freundinnen und sie könnten und
es muss einfach wieder bis umsonst die
gabig lange für Lebensmittel
und wenn es nicht mit ihnen hat
und dann gibt es nicht mehr oder sie
leben vor Reste
oder Spaghetti und mit dem Bargeld
können
was kostet das Leben
und sie würden sicher aufgehen eine
andere Möglichkeit für Donald aus seiner
Misere rauszukommen wäre ein
Restschuldbefreiungsverfahren bei dem
man nicht mehr auf das Einverständnis
der Gläubiger angewiesen ist ein solches
wird im Moment auf politischer Ebene
diskutiert
Eve the Mistral macht sich seit längerem
dafür stark an einer Tagung des
Dachverbandes der Schweizer
Schuldenberatungsstellen zur
Vernehmlassung des neuen Gesetzes ist er
als Referent eingeladen
verschiedene Varianten während
diskutiert
34 Jahre Wohlverhalten
Möglichkeit
hat auch ein mehrstufiges Verfahren und
dann als letztes Deutschland das auch
davon ausgeht dass die verschuldeten
eine zweite Chance verdient haben
in schuldenberatungskreisen ist man sich
einig dass ein
Restschuldbefreiungsverfahren für die
Betroffenen für die Gesellschaft und für
die Wirtschaft Vorteile hätte weil
überschuldete so wieder am
Wirtschaftsleben teilnehmen könnten
damit sie konsumieren damit sie die
Wirtschaft Alkohol dazu ist dass er bei
dir aber den haben wo arbeitet ihre
Kredit nicht
Minderheit für das zahlen alle anderen
sind das eigentlich
entschuldige das ist eigentlich ein
Porno wollte
kreditkonsumkredit finanzieren
besonders
Möglichkeiten entschuldigen
in der Schweiz betragen die
Gesamtschulden von Privatpersonen aus
verlustscheinen mindestens 20 Milliarden
Franken nur gerade 17 Prozent davon
können zurückbezahlt werden
wo praktisch nichts zu holen ist wie bei
Donald würde eine solche Entschuldung
Sinn machen meint der Mistral
kann abliefern
oder maximal vier Jahre befristet dass
er weiß 4 Jahre muss ich durch durch die
Härte zieht oder aber nachher auch nicht
Motivation zum zum
ich danke schön wäre
[Musik]
in der Zwischenzeit hat Donald die
Fußfesseln bekommen um so die Strafe aus
seinen sprayer-aktivitäten abzuzahlen
[Musik]
am Anfang extrem unrealistisch gesehen
wie das Ganze so wieder ganz greifbar
jetzt noch knapp 3,5
das da bin ich noch hier vor allem so
auf der viererarbeiter
[Musik]
und manchmal Verspätungen
zwei Monate muss er noch dadurch wird
sein Schuldenberg kleiner aber es
bleiben immer noch rund 73.000 Franken
mit abzahlen geht es nur herzlich
vorwärts
[Musik]
eigentlich obwohl man schon versucht
haben
[Musik]
es ist mega Strang und härter aber mit
Erfolgserlebnis gespickt eigentlich
andauernd und wenn man sich eben
wirklich dem annimmt mit und
[Musik]
sich aber das Zeug halten
und vielleicht wird ja aus seinem
Projekt mit den Kalk Graffitis doch noch
was
für donald ist es nur schon ein Erfolg
zu merken dass er aktiv etwas tun kann
um seine Situation zu verbessern
[Musik]
auch für Erika wird es immer besser als
sie mit der Schuldensanierung begonnen
hat ist sie mit einer Kollegin zusammen
in eine WG gezogen und konnte so ihre
Wohn- und Haushaltskosten massiv
reduzieren
eine sehr süß
das macht der Hund pro Woche
nach Bezahlung von Krankenkasse Handy
und Strom bleiben Erika so noch drei bis
400 Franken im Monat weil sie nicht mehr
auswärts ist reicht das gut eigentlich
ja es langt immer mehr
Erika hat sich von ihrer Depression
erholt sie weiß auch dass ihre
Durststrecke nicht mehr so lange dauern
wird
[Musik]
unnötige Sachen
und das schaffe über jeder Scheiß hat
ihn jemand